basically what we had is a bunch of
people who went to school in an
environment in which they got a's for
effort
deploying effort at controlling this
pandemic right now the point really is i
put in the time yeah i put in the time
and i came up with a plan oh what was
your plan my plan was to have people
walk one direction through the garden
while wearing their masks right
i spent all of yesterday at this and i
came up with something i think it's
really good
what's good about it well i don't know
but it's really changing people's
behavior in a way that has something to
do with the pandemic right and we do
like changing people's behavior don't we
so the point is it's like people are
actually convinced that the fact that
they've put in a lot of effort is
tantamount to them having done something
useful now we watched our public health
authorities if we give our public health
authorities the benefit of the doubt and
we say it's hard actually
they were trying to control the pandemic
well then what they proved is it's
really hard this was such a contagious
disease that human efforts were swept
aside by this incredibly powerful
pathogen that you know yes we very
likely cooked up in a laboratory you
know from a natural ancestor but yes
turbocharged the thing and then the
point is human control wasn't gonna
happen right i did believe that two
years ago
what
that they were really trying well you
know i don't think they were really
trying because i don't think they could
have failed as badly as they did but
i know but i but i said i did believe
that two years ago i started out with
i'm not saying that i believe that that
was i believe now that was two years ago
are you saying you didn't believe that
two years ago um
i was a little bit agnostic but i was
certainly it was my assumption yeah and
then it broke very quickly and the
farther they were it seemed like trump
was just doing a terrible job and
yes trump was
reading stuff on the internet and
spouting off about it which is not a
good control mechanism but frankly it's
as good as anything they did so um
but anyway the point is look so
you know in a world where you were not
led to believe that effort is what the
universe is monitoring right there would
be two questions okay we've got a
dangerous pandemic
what is the likelihood that by doing
something we will make it better it's
not obvious right
in fact i think the real
comparison that we need to look at is
what if i don't not suggesting you do
nothing you don't pretend that people
are getting you don't acknowledge people
are getting sick right you don't pretend
that there's no pandemic but if we had
simply allowed
doctors to do what doctors do right and
let scientists study the thing and see
what they could figure out and not tried
to rush in with a top-down plan that
turned out to make things much worse in
my estimation
right we probably would have done better
but the idea that
we're going to control this in a useful
way all right we're going to on whatever
organization you run whether it's a
school or a garden or whatever you're
going to need to put in some effort
right that's how we're going to control
this thing um yeah and then everybody
comes up with their thing and basically
i think they feel rewarded
based on the fact that they know they've
done something and it has changed
something that they can see well and
it's consistent with the idea of work
being inherently valuable yeah right and
this you know i i quoted a little bit
from graber's [ __ ] jobs a few weeks
ago
and um
and you know he goes into the history in
in that book and you know again it's
been a little while now since i read it
still sitting here um
i i don't remember all of it but you
know that's
that's not
uh a universal from history you know we
didn't always assume
that you know
just doing stuff that someone else is
paying you for
is of value right and we seem to have
taken that on and i do wonder how that
interfaces with for instance the you
know ascendancy of the protestant work
ethic which
you know i wasn't raised by protestants
but um that was certainly you know that
was that was part of our home culture
for sure you know i was gonna get a job
early and i you know and and you you
know in practice and you know just
working hard at things was how it was
that you were going to both perfect your
own
self and your skills and also therefore
make enough of yourself that you had
reason to expect that you would get
ahead right um all of these made sense
but then the kinds of things that i was
doing and that my family was doing
were and i i could be wrong about this
but it all felt like it was inherently
of value
right and so much of what people are
being paid to do now and this is
graeber's point with regard to [ __ ]
jobs which again he distinguishes from
[ __ ] jobs where which tend to be jobs
that are need to be done in the world
but pay terribly no no [ __ ] jobs are
jobs that need to be done but tend to be
tend to pay terribly and [ __ ] jobs
um about which the book is written um
are jobs that largely don't need to be
done even most of the people many of the
people doing them don't need to know
they need to be done but they tend to
bring white-collar wages with them
and um the rise of the [ __ ] job is
uh a not just an absurdity uh but you
know maybe a contributor to the fermi
paradox frankly you know like we've got
a whole lot of people
like presumably the people making policy
at things like schools and gardens and
such
we were like oh boy we got to put some
effort in we got to do some work i'm
going to need that gold star stamped on
my forehead okay we've got a plan
well is it a good plan well but it's a
plan we've worked hard on it and we're
going to have to work hard to implement
it we're going to have to work hard and
maybe we'll come up with plan 2.0 at
some point but we certainly have to
implement plan 1.0 first so let's go
and it feels like
effort and effort feels like
it must be good
and it must not be good effort
there is nothing inherently good about
having spent time at something no and in
fact it's bad
um
so two things one if you compare let's
say take the japanese garden as a
microcosm
right if the japanese garden had not put
in a lot of effort on a plan
it would have meant people would have
walked chaotically through the garden
where nobody would have gotten covered
because they were outside so the point
is you can compare these two things now
the one marginal difference
is their indoor spaces and those indoor
spaces it may have mattered you know
certainly a ventilation plan would
greatly reduce the chances of somebody
contracting it
at the japanese garden in an indoor
space and you know the three indoor
spaces that i can think of granted
they're small
but they didn't have the arrows
you could walk chaotically in the indoor
spaces right so what they came up with
was a plan
that probably did no good changed a lot
of people's behavior
and i find you know i
who reject in training so actively who
think about this i've been thinking
about this for decades
found myself in trained
which means i think i because i am so
aware of the hazards of this i think and
is one of the things that i think about
a lot i think it means that almost
everyone will have been entrained by
things that they have not yet seen or
detected and that we should all
try to become conscious of the ways in
which that has happened and break it and
this is you know harking back to wendell
berry's manifesto the mad farmer
liberation mad farmer's liberation front
that i read last week and then i also
posted on my sub stack this week
um
you know do do something every day that
surprises them that does not compute
be the kind of person that does not
compute with some regularity so that you
aren't in trainable untrainable which is
which is why that scene that i've
mentioned in the truman show where
truman has caught on enough
that he becomes unpredictable and he's
driving around the roundabout and nobody
can predict which exit he's going to
take right it's that
um but okay i wanted to return to this
question about you know
spending time is not inherently good
effort is not inherently good i once
surprised myself by
pointing this out i think at the very
beginning of
one of the programs i taught at
evergreen
and
i was shocked at my students reaction
because what i said
is that work is not good
and they were like
and i was shocked that this was
surprising to them because to me it
seems pretty obvious
that if you have two individuals who
both produce something of equal quality
and one of them has spent a quarter as
much time at it that that's actually the
more
adept person and that we should all be
striving
for a given level of product we should
be striving to invest as little time and
it doesn't mean that you don't want to
invest more time but it means if you're
going to invest more time you want to
get more out of it and so you know it's
it's a
the investment is a necessary evil the
point is
you we like people who work hard because
they tend to produce things but we
should not like people who waste their
effort okay but so you're going to be
misunderstood two ways i think
only two
well i i can see how i would
misunderstand you two ways
if i did not know you well and had not
taught with you in several situations
i'll probably forget one of them while i
speak to the first
um
the first is that um
let's see you call it productive goofing
off is that what you call it
you do a lot of stuff you spend a lot of
your time
that to
anyone outside of you
looks like you're not doing anything yep
and um
zach is laughing you're like it's just
true i am not here slandering my husband
this is just true and it's real i mean
you've you've taken it to quite a level
um and you are actually you are actually
doing work you are actually doing
intellectual work
um and so you know
to to fit into your equation you kind of
you can't cheat you got to count that as
time spent oh right but it doesn't look
like what people expect you to look like
when you're spending time on a project
on an intellectual project so that's one
thing that you actually do spend a
tremendous amount of time but it you
know often it's
you know the stereotype is like in the
shower like people have have their ideas
in the shower and that's true too but
you know biking or just fiddling
yeah here you can have that back
uh yes occasionally i will take the
things you're filling with away
um because i can't take it
good lord um and your younger son has
picked this up hasn't yet it's driving
me crazy so there's at least some
justice in there we were watching the
three of us zach was out um doing tech
production on a play last night and uh
brett and toby 15 and i were sitting
watching a show and like
three times during the show i
carefully
reached over and grabbed the
remote out of toby's hand not because i
want it i actually don't even know where
the buttons are on and it's not backlit
but because he was messing with it and
the batteries are coming out oh my god
you too just
stop anyway you are productive doing
this okay and you spend time in a way
that doesn't look like productive but it
is and so that's one thing
is that they you know they whoever they
are have an idea of what productive
looks like and it's mostly the kind of
thing that you see and again a third
grade classroom with people with little
boys and girls
and girls are much better at this than
boys are um sitting very quietly and
neatly in their rows with you know
whatever it is they're expected to have
in front of them and they raise their
hand nicely and politely when they're
called out when they have an idea or
they need to use the bathroom and it
does a great job of creating cogs and it
does not do a great job of creating
innovative thinkers and creators and
explorers and adventurers and
innovators and all these things that's
one
the second way that you will be
misunderstood
i knew i was going to forget it
is ah
we had a
we did in a couple of the programs that
we taught and i think i actually started
it um first in one that i taught and i
don't think it was as effective when i
did it alone is when we did it together
then uh called learn a skill okay
and uh learn a skill we we did this in
um
freshman first year programs and maybe
an all-year program i mean at all level
program but mostly it was um
the the idea you know formally it was
remember evergreen was full-time program
so we had these students for um you know
either a full quarter or two quarters or
three quarters but they're full time
their full-time college experience was
supposed to be us and we'd spend you
know 15 to 20 hours a week in class with
them or you know all week if we were on
a field trip but then they were expected
to spend you know the equivalent of a
full-time job 40 hours at at the work at
the academic work
of our program whatever it was
and so uh learn a skill uh was
formalized like you know i had i had it
all written out like you will pick a
thing which has some physical uh
ramification in the world like carpentry
or playing the guitar or or
baking yeast breads i don't know
um and we had a list of possibilities
and we said if none of these appeal to
you um you know pitch us your own idea
but we're not going to let you just do
anything because it has to have physical
manifestations in the world it has to be
of sufficient complexity that you can't
simply master it in two hours
the key thing is it has to be evident
when you fail
right so physical manifestation of
manifestation in the world could mean
doodling but the problem is
it can't be subjective whether or not
you've succeeded at it yes and i i set
up a minimum expectation of hours per
week and it wasn't a huge number it was
like
i could go back and look but i feel like
it was four or something so it was like
over the course of a quarter just like
40 hours and then they there were
check-ins there was a check-in uh midway
through the quarter public check-in like
everyone had to get up and spend like
one minute saying you know what it was
um how well they were doing and
and you know how how well they were
making progress on their own goals and
then at the end they got like three
minutes because we had 50 students and
we had other presentations like more
academic stuff as well
and the point was not
did you learn how to make a table or you
know did you learn your g chords
um it was
what did you learn about your own
internal motivation
and you know did you in fact spend
the four hours a week
and we asked for
we asked for we mostly got i think
remarkably complete honesty from
students even the ones who just didn't
spend the time because again
the point was and i think how i
formalized it in what i was what i said
to them about it was
um
failure is possible and fine
failing to fail
is what we are trying to avoid at all
costs if you fail to fail it's because
you just didn't put in the time and so
this is where this is how you're going
to be misunderstood by saying it's not
about putting in the time there are some
things where you really do need to put
in the time oh well no i i was very
careful i am not saying don't work i am
saying we esteem people who work because
work is important but it's a necessary
evil given that you are trying to
accomplish something the question is how
you know
the x is a something it may take you a
half a lifetime to do it right but the
point is it should take you a half a
lifetime because that's how long it took
to get there not because you wasted
three quarters of that time that you
could have spent on some other project
so it was like do enough work to get the
damn thing done
but
don't waste your time at it which
actually comes with another important
lesson that i found students had a hard
time with which was there are a lot of
thing this goes back to the question of
is there something useful to do
i would say for me
the kind of work that i professionally
do my theoretical work
almost every
important success i have had in making a
breakthrough
involved
figuring out what the puzzle is
and then putting it aside and not trying
to force the answer because i didn't
have
all of the important pieces of
information to finish the thing until
later and so the point is if your point
is look i'm going to work on this puzzle
for two years
you may not be able to get to an answer
in five years in 10 years it may it may
be that you're waiting for something to
show up to complete the puzzle and at
the point that you stop making progress
the point is i'm not quitting the
project i am putting it on a back burner
and i will know when to pull it off that
back burner and revive it because now i
suddenly know the thing i didn't know
well and you were allowing for mental
meandering you were allowing for
serendipity you were allowing for you
know the you know the larger time scale
equivalent of dream space to enter into
your thinking and so you know in
academia the the model that we are
taught
that we are told in most fields not the
arts
is you know and not the experimental
sciences either but many many fields is
you have an idea you accumulate
everything that anyone has ever written
about that idea you become familiar with
what everyone has already said about it
and from there you cobble together the
pieces um you know the evidence either
for or against yours or you just review
what they've done and you create
something that's a little bit new and
you know over in science space i call
this brick in the wall science
um and you know it's it's valuable that
some people are doing brick in the wall
science but you will always have the
same foundation of the house that you
started with with brick and noel science
and it's possible the foundation of the
house you started with uh is not the
foundation um that you want or that is
true so you know there's there's a
problem with um enforcing brick in the
wall science and um you know complete
literature-based review never shall
the truth shall never be outside of the
literature-based science um to the
exclusion of all other approaches
because you can't have um you can't have
revolutionary ideas you can't have
paradigm shifts with that
yes in fact so
um this is an incredibly important point
you have to have people i mean there's
there's a way in which brick in the wall
science is a bridge too far i think for
anybody
but
it may but it's what most people do oh
it is certainly what most people do and
the point is it's actually
antithetical to breakthrough science if
you have everybody do it then there are
no breakthroughs and the point is the
bricks in the wall are less and less
meaningful if they are not stacked on
some breakthrough that's actually taking
you somewhere because diminishing
returns means smaller and smaller bricks
you're not really building anything of
value and so
it's a catastrophe
the whole idea of
well surely if you're going to make
progress on this set of puzzles you will
want to know everything everyone has
done on the way there and the answer is
by the time you learn everything
everyone has done on the way there a you
will have spent
a huge amount of time and made no
progress and b even worse you will be
entrained right you will be entrained in
the thought process that got them stuck
in the first place and this all
very counter-intuitive do you want to
know everything that is known before you
try to add anything the answer is you
probably don't you'll ask better
questions now you'll ask some bad ones
right you'll ask some questions that
other people have figured their way past
but you'll ask some good ones that
nobody's asked yet and that's where the
breakthroughs live
[Music]